المنسق الاممي الخاص لعمليه السلام في
الشرق الاوسط سورب عن قلقه اذا زياده
مستويات العنف المرتبط بالمستوطنين في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله وحتى خلال جلسه
مفتوحه لمجلس الامن بشان الاوضاع في الشرق
الاوسط حتى اسرائيل على تقيد بالتزاماتها
بموجب القانون الدولي لحمايه الفلسطينيين
من جميع اعمال العنف او التهديدات بالعنف
حسب تعبيره
بقلق عميق ازاء زياده مستويات العنف
المرتبط بالمستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله في بعض الاحيان بالقرب من قوات
الامن الاسرائيليه انني مرعوب بشكل خاص من
التسلسل الوحشي للاحداث في حواره تجب
محاسبه جميع الجنات احس اسرائيل بصفتها
السلطه القائمه بالاحتلال على التقيد
بالتزاماتها بموجب القانون الدولي لحمايه
سكان الفلسطينيين من جميع اعمال العنف او
التهديدات بالعنف
كما اكد المنسق الاممي الخاص لعمليه
السلام في الشرق الاوسط على انه يجب على
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي استخدام القوه
المميته فقط عندما لا يمكن تجنبها لحمايه
الارواح وقال المناسق الاممي ان عمليات
قوات الاحتلال في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
خلفت عددا هائلا من القتلى والجرحى بين
الفلسطينيين
ادت عمليات القوات الاسرائيليه في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله ومتلاها من الشباكات الى
عدد هائل من القتلى والجرحى من
الفلسطينيين اجدد التاكيد على انه يجب على
هذه القوات ان تستخدم القوه المميته فقط
عندما لا يمكن تجنبها تماما لحمايه
الارواح ويجب التحقيق بشكل سريع وشامل في
جميع حالات الوفاه او الاصابه الناتجه عن
استخدام القوه ومحاسبه المسؤولين عن